étranger
C, nous voulons que les gens sachent que ce
médicament existe, qu'il est sûr et
efficace et qu'il est disponible
partout aux États-Unis dans tous les codes postaux et qu'un
écosystème de ressources existe
actuellement pour aider quelqu'un à prendre la
décision qui lui convient le mieux
euh
et en ce moment, nous faisons passer le mot
sur la fourniture avancée ou les pilules
avant d'en avoir besoin
au cas où, c'est donc à la fois une
approche très pratique pour garantir
votre propre accès à l'avortement face aux
interdictions nuisibles et c'est aussi  un symbole de
défi que nous disons que
les pilules abortives ne vont nulle part
[Musique]
merci pour l'opportunité d'être ici
Je n'ai pas de déclaration préparée mais je
voudrais remercier les personnes qui
m'ont amené à ce point personne  est en train de créer
ce qui pourrait très justement être
considéré comme un pays qui existe
depuis plus de deux décennies et qui a fait l'objet
de recherches, de documents et
de preuves avec toutes ces preuves comme étant un
étranger très sûr